number one i want to believe
number two fortress
number three mistrust
number four eight slices
and number five
ladies quilt club scandal
which of these movie titles do you think
is fake
um
let's see
i would say
if i did a search on imdb
either
eight slices or i want to believe
and i would have to say probably eight
slices
you think that's a fake
possibly it feels like it
of these five titles which movie title
catches your eye where you might want to
see that film
probably the ladies quilt club scandal
sure yeah okay i i feel like it could be
in the genre of horror it could be scary
okay
or maybe only scary to a six year old
i'm not sure
perhaps uh it depends
how would you rate these titles from
best to worst best to worst
so
we'll say
the best one being number five as far as
or like
the first one or how the first one i say
would be the best sure okay all right
let's do that okay
um
your favorite yeah
uh the
best one
of all these
mistrust
would be
my top one
uh i like the way these two t's are i
feel like i could see a poster where
that could really go into it maybe the
t's are leaking into some background
imagery
uh the second one would be fortress
because one word titles are always
better than anything else to a degree in
my opinion
uh and then the third one
i would say would be ladies quilt
club scandal
just because i want that to be my number
third not necessarily i really think
it's the number third but then
i'd probably say i want to believe four
and then the fifth one would be eight
slices
okay
i don't like the way the eight looks
with uh
with the word slices next to it it's
just one of those things that
would it be better if it was the word
eight you think like maybe but eight
slices feels like a c movie that the
title was chosen because it's going to
be above the a category on the list you
know where it's going to be all these
numbered movies you're like what are
these 55 movies i have no idea what they
are eight slices that should be a sci-fi
and it should be about alien pizza
aliens come here and we eat their pizza
and then we become aliens maybe that's
what it is maybe it's a brand new
maybe we should do that it could be the
sequel to killer clowns from outer space
and i'm just kidding killer clowns
matter of space is an amazing movie so
okay anyway okay we'll revisit uh eight
slices in just one moment
what would you say are the genres for
each of these movies
do i need to say a title and then the
genre or should i point to them and say
them or um i think if you don't mind
just saying it yeah the titles someone
tunes in late okay all right um
let's see so eight slices should be
sci-fi okay ladies quilt club scandal is
definitely horror
mistrust is psychological thriller
fortress is a good old-fashioned war
film
i want to believe is a trump documentary
okay okay great
if you had to pick one of these five
titles for your next film which one
would you pick mistrust miss trust okay
yeah yeah it seems like that you really
like that that's good it's like a good
strong title it's a strong title
you know immediately i want to get kathy
bates in it
and
you know maybe we do a different take on
misery where she ends up being the one
in the bed and someone else is
yeah i don't know mistrust or
or you get chris crispin glover
back
and have him in it and it's almost like
get him in it as willard
and have him in i don't know mistrust i
don't know there's something in there
with either crisp and crisp and glover
and and kathy bates should be in the
movie and they should be family there it
is i could see it also being a legal
thriller too
kind of like the firm
but yeah anyway okay i'm i'm not
supposed to be giving answers so here
sorry i'm overstubbing my bounce so
mistrust is the one that you like the
most and what would the plot be you just
kind of
lightly gave us something but yeah
mistrust is about a mother-son story
where the sun is trying to deal with his
body dysmorphia but the mother doesn't
know he's suffering from body dysmorphia
so he he's going through these bouts
where he's not eating now they live on a
farm and they're isolated and the mother
she likes to play her little video games
but the sun gets angry at her and one
day he ends up
deactivating their electricity and then
the second half of the film they're in
the dark with candles and she begins to
get paranoid about them and
unfortunately for him she's been doing
dealing with her own delusions
and um
so it ends up you know obviously the
third act is gonna be pretty harrowing
and we'll see which one of these two
people come out alive
so the so not having electricity
strips away any distractions strips it
away makes them to where they have to
deal with each other confront each other
and in the heat of the ending
where he tells her the truth that the
son that she adopted he actually
murdered
she actually tells him her own truth and
that he's adopted himself
and
i hate to spoil it but right right
mistrust mistrust wow coming in just a
few months right okay
so maybe not not do you think what what
network would show that film oh fx
or you know or maybe the sundance
channel
hbo max would want it but we went in
seleton oh no no we tell hbo
you know it's not the right fit
sure we want to be on fx not hallmark
no no no no not hallmark you know okay
it might be a little too dark no not at
all
i like fx because fx is in the middle of
the country in rural areas
where a lot of people want to see your
cinema like i actually in truth
an ep of mine was talking about where
where would you want you know this next
picture to end up and i want my my next
movie to end up in all these rural areas
i want people that wouldn't have hbo
that wouldn't have these other
streaming services to just come in off
of their hard job sit down flick on the
television and there on fx could be your
movie
i'm not sponsored by fx i just want to
make that clear i just watched a lot of
it growing up sure sure
that's that's awesome okay
so of all the movie titles of which
which ones are true which ones weren't
and what they're about i'll reveal the
sort of synopsis here so number one i
want to believe is a documentary
by jay horton who's a filmmaker we've
we've interviewed so i was right about
the documentary you were right you were
right however but it's not about trump
though well not quite it's a thrilling
study of the ufo phenomenon and the
people who decided uh their lives or
excuse me the people who dedicate their
lives to present credible information
for skeptics and believers alike
so i want to believe i love ufos okay
great i'm gonna check out this
documentary okay wonderful jay horton
and then fortress is an action film and
it's also by a filmmaker we've
interviewed james cullen bressack
and it is a group of criminals led by
robert's former nemesis which is uh bald
who is hellbent on revenge and forces a
retired cia agent and his estranged son
into a high-tech bunker
will the thick walls and defenses be
powerful enough against this enemy's
forces
so it's a revenge action film
number three pretty much in the war
space too yeah i mean there's there's a
sort of military government aspect to it
right right
uh number three is mistrust that is a
romantic drama by shane stanley who
we've interviewed here
and this is uh having no commitments and
never having been vulnerable veronica
enjoys being a mistress oh wow and yeah
and she comes to realize her best friend
holds the key to her heart and is the
only one capable of extracting her
emotions
sounds good to me um
number four eight slices
it is a real film it's a drama
by nick westfall and it's produced by
rampus merthel who we've had on
and i've actually watched this film some
of the other films i actually haven't
watched eight slices is actually
excellent it was um
it's about a new hire who joins a small
town pizza restaurant just as the
business
fails and its employees question the
american dream and it has a lot to do
with influencer culture
i don't want to give away too much about
it but it's actually i really enjoyed it
so eight slices so it's not a sci-fi
it's not a sci-fi no no
it's really well done and then number
five ladies quilt club scandal that i
made up
okay so uh but thank you thank you for
choosing it and um
i just thought that would be you know
sort of throw people off a little bit
because the quilt club you think of you
know nice ladies you know talking about
their grandchildren maybe and you would
never expect a scandal to break out but
it does well you know i felt like it
could be a good murder mystery
oh i was thinking more sort of uh
hidden money in the walls ponzi scheme
something like that where these ladies
were being used and they didn't realize
what they had gotten themselves into
nicely or or a group of older women got
together with no health ailments
and they decided they were going to lie
to the government about a bunch of
health issues to get a ton of money
that could and they just seem totally
and and they start buying porsches
and buying this crazy flashy stuff and
we can make a reality show out of it
yeah i guess so all right but these were
actually my these were good ladies these
and somehow they got suckered in by the
wrong person so
but uh anyway i don't really have it
fully fleshed out it was just
but thank you for choosing it yeah